[Musique]
croyez-vous au martial je crois oui j'y
crois
non je n'y crois pas pourquoi si je n'ai
pas vu de mes yeux je peux pas y croire
et vous personnellement j'y crois mais
je ne voudrais pas rentrer à bord c'est
comme dire que l'os est imaginaire que
pensez vous des gens qui s'y croient cd
blagueur ils font ça pour se faire
connaître comme à les imaginer vos
[Musique]
grands acquis un gros ventre de l'ombre
et vous des antennes des grandes
oreilles
c'en est sans cheveux et joue moi je
crois qu'ils auraient plus peut-être
l'air des hommes enfin comme des hommes
des sortes de robots
il ne serait pas comme nous différents
bon il ne marche pas comme nos quelques
images alors peut-être du sable de la
rue de la sinne pensez vous qu'ils
utilisent de l'essence pour faire
marcher leurs machines
j'espère que non parce qu'il ya déjà des
restrictions de sang selon la cassure et
vos réactions si vous en rencontrez un
fonds pourrait les invités à boire un
coup ou giscard
de quelle manière les pelouses les
accueillerez vous je leur dirai de venir
manger chez moi le genre de demande de
me faire faire à tour en soucoupe
je vais mènera vais-je la même heure
avec mon cinéma moi je donnerai un bon
petit plomb dans les fesses garantie
d'avant ça dépasse ils sont
bruel gérard chez eux je partirai
j'avertirai la police pourquoi ben je ne
resterai pas sur place j'ai pas envie
qu'ils qui me touche quoi
je ne cherche pas la bagarre moore si
vous voyez marciel que lui diriez vous
je lui dirai l'est mont-bleu les mots
qu'on dit avec les yeux pensez vous
qu'un jour ils concluront la tête ça
dépend il ya des moments oui du moment
non j'espère que nos 1
j'espère rester libre quand même ce
possible ils ont peut-être plus fort que
nous j'aurais peur pourquoi auriez vous
peur parce qu'elles seront pas comme
nous seulement pour ça oui et vous au
je n'aurai pas peur je serai peut-être
qu'ils sont des êtres comme nous un peu
peut-être un peu plus intelligent ils
doivent être dur à manipuler
aimeriez-vous qu'ils existent
oui s'ils viennent pour nous détruire
non monsieur viennent en amuse bouche ou
via le marcia je m'en fous mais là
marcel je la garde
[Musique]